i don't think the aura were a
particularly good villain for stargate
let's talk about that
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
the aura
superpower descended beings with powers
beyond your imagination being the main
protagonist for seasons 9 and 10 of
stargate sg1
but i don't think they're actually that
great i've got a few reasons why the uri
storyline actually didn't make that much
sense and why they weren't really a
great villain okay so let's lay down
some ground rules let's establish what
the alright actually are
they are what the ancients essentially
used to be they are part of the same
society they are for all intents and
purposes the same species who have just
ascended to a higher plane of existence
they now live on a different plane they
now have super powers and they
quite possibly have the infinite
knowledge of the universe now unlike the
ancients of the milky way and pegasus
galaxy the ori do not have a
non-interference policy meaning that
they can basically do whatever they want
within their own galaxy okay so we first
see the aura in season nine of stargate
sg1 where they use the communication
stones and inadvertently transport
themselves to a galaxy occupied by the
aura daniel jackson and valor inhabit
the bodies of these two unsuspecting
people and that basically find out that
there's this whole society uh centered
around the religion of origin now they
are in these bodies for a really really
long time and they are eventually
discovered but they are discovered by
the people
and the priors rather than by the aura
themselves now the aura are supposed to
be all seeing all knowing
infinite beings of ascended pure
brilliance but they couldn't detect
someone
traveling between a galaxy using these
little stones to inhabit someone else's
body like there has to be some kind of
signal between that stone and the one in
the milky way so how did they not detect
it how did they not realize that someone
from a completely different galaxy was
inhabiting one of their own followers
bodies and why did they never show
themselves we know that they do not
follow the non-interference policy like
the ascendant agents in our galaxy do
and even they show themselves to us from
time to time but the ascended or i never
do the best we get is a big fiery
flaming head
goes into the doci and speaks through
him if you are a super powered ascended
being ball of energy fire breathing
thing
you should be able to at least take
human form and you know
threaten the people rather than using
priors and the whole thing about wanting
everyone in the galaxy to worship you so
you can get more power just doesn't make
any sense how does me believing in
something
transfer my energy into you that makes
no sense whatsoever now also
this is another reason why the ori just
as a as a species are completely stupid
they use their followers to create ships
they basically gave the information to
the doci who gave it to the priors who
then gave it to
the village people who then became
armies and builders uh to give them
plans to build these giant starships now
if you are an ascended being uh i don't
think it's
be
i don't think it's a reaching statement
to assume that you could literally
fabricate anything
in an instance we have seen technology
from the ancients
on our plane of existence where they can
fabricate things
straight away they can make it with
machinery now if you are an ascended
being with all this power of the
universe on all this knowledge
you should be able to just go like that
and the starship appears
why why did you have to get your
followers to do it if you were a
god-like being with all this power
surely you would want to demonstrate
that to your followers because
if somehow the transference of my belief
in you makes you more powerful than you
coming down
showing your face to me saying hello i
am your god and going boom
starship
that would make me believe in you a
little bit more that would make me
believe in you a hell of a lot also i
don't think it is sustainable for you as
a benevolent god you know you are an
ascended being who has all this power uh
to rule with fear like you want people
to believe in you because you want them
to believe you are their gods and that
you created them which you may very well
have done you may have seeded the galaxy
with human life that's what the ancients
did in our galaxy but we don't we don't
think of them as gods
if you want them to believe you are a
god show yourself to them perform some
miracles
don't get the priors to do it because
surely they're going to be worshiping
the priors rather than worshiping the
aura that's something i never understood
surely the people of the uri galaxy were
just worshipping them and not the actual
aura themselves and finally my my final
point i want to make on the uri and how
stupid the whole storyline was
is the fact that
when you ascend
you go to a higher plane of existence
now i
never assumed or never thought that the
higher plane of existence also had
galaxies
i assumed it was a different realm and
where you know ascended beings could
congregate and do whatever ascended
beings do i didn't think they were
borders and that is very much what is
suggested with the uruguay storyline our
ancients protected us from them
and shielded our existence
because they weren't in our galaxy so
essentially there is a ascended realm in
the milky way there is another one in
the eurogalaxy and there will probably
be others popping up all around the
universe and that just doesn't make much
sense to me
surely it would all be one
massive thing and if you do have
infinite power infinite knowledge rather
of the universe you would just be able
to be like oh yeah there's some humans
over there let's go and let's go and
take them over like
come on come on well i think we can
accept here that matthew doesn't know
his elbow from his all right
so on thursday i'm going to be doing my
video with my take on the aura from
stargate sg1 and i think you'll find
that um you'll be convinced that
everything matthew has just said is a
load of twaddle
so i'll see you on thursday guys
well
do you like the ori yes or no let me
know in the comment section down below
if you are new to the youtube channel
hit subscribe and hit the bell
notification so you do not miss a single
video and also whilst you're down there
consider becoming a fully fledged
sidetracked member hit the join button
down below thank you so much for
watching and i'll see you
next week
[Music]
you